all right
she's holding her own yeah I mean this
is frightening two grown men and a young
girl oh
my God
the worst part is knowing that they were
just doing it alive I know
you look at it oh look
oh
keep shopping
cool
you know this is a good plan this is a
smart plan yeah oh well yeah I would
have yelled it earlier when I was
breaking his fingers
okay are you okay you're okay she
doesn't freaking know she's in five I
know I know
and so insane seeing like
a girl
that production blood is so bright
like the watches oh the watch yeah yeah
it was broken
together as Jack
well it looks like you gave the
penicillin
correct she did it right she did it
right is he is walking I mean he healed
up pretty pretty yeah that was pretty
good pretty much good I wish it didn't
look like they were walking just
straight into them I know it does look
like let's go for a swim huh cut into
the lake perfect welcome back to New
Rock so I was The Last of Us episode
eight when we are in need is here and I
need a [__] vacation after watching
that holy cow I and I do have a vacation
I'm going to Virginia
vacation this is the break room Our
Daily Show that keeps you updated on all
the nerdy news you need to know and
today we're talking about The Last of Us
episode eight so grab some venison
it's not actual venison baby and the
nearest butcher knife as we dive into
this episode I'm Jessica Clemens here
with me today is Brandon Barrick oh you
know it didn't look that bad it looked
pretty tasty yeah as long as I don't
know I will consume it yeah yeah and
Anna vanston yeah I eat humans but only
socially
that's good that's good you never want
to eat humans by yourself that's when
you know you have a problem that's when
you have a problem hey before we dive
into it today don't forget to check out
nerd riot.shop where you can still grab
this and I mean this exact One Last of
Us inspired shirt lost in the darkness
I'll sell it to you the one I'm wearing
right now also you can check out the
link in this video's description where
you can grab this jacket from huckberry
this is the same jacket that Joel's
wears in the show we haven't seen it for
a while because it's been covered up but
now we saw it again you keep saying the
same it's really like where's on the
show and he's changing the job I know
but he took his jacket off this time the
bigger over coat now you saw this jacket
and I will say it's been very cold and
and rainy and even snowy here in Los
Angeles and this jacket has kept me warm
good yeah
take it off I refuse to take it off I
refuse to shower I refuse to do anything
that Joel can't do okay as a reminder
this first part of the episode will be
spoiler free we recommend if you haven't
played the games to avoid reading the
comments if you don't want to be spoiled
if you're in the comments be nice don't
spoil everything we won't be talking
about game stuff or what we know what's
going to happen in the show uh in this
first part of the episode we'll leave
all that stuff out until uh at the end
of the episode we'll warn you before we
get into spoilers for now it's just a
recap of episode 8 so let's get into it
this episode opens on the resort town of
Silver Lake shout out to East L.A baby
can't afford to live there
well you can during then you can I could
live in this silver like I could afford
it inside Todd's Steakhouse the towns
Church slash cafeteria slash morgue
slash giant fireplace David uh played by
Scott Shepard reads a passage from The
Book of Revelations always a good sign
when the pastor is opening with the Book
of Revelations well yeah once you make
it to that point you know you're at a
good church yeah yeah any any evil
preacher out there starts off with the
Book of Revelation so always be wary if
if the pastor starts getting into the
Pale Rider on the horse and his name was
death you know when I buy no that's what
I call Bible it's that hit is always
it's always on there anyway behind him
hangs a sign reading when we are in need
he shall provide do we think the sign is
referring to God or David at this point
because I think it's David I mean he
clearly has a God complex right yeah I
mean who doesn't in this uh apocalyptic
post whatever the hell you want to call
it a young girl sobs through the passage
her father having recently passed away
David tells her that her father cannot
be buried until the spring when the
ground isn't Frozen good one David we
all believe you yeah we can't bury dad
till after lunch don't worry about it
okay take him to the river or something
I was like
interaction with that girl really
really yeah you notice now this guy's a
creep is the second time around we later
learned or at least it's implied that
her father is one that is the one that
got Joel uh with the butt of the
baseball bat and can I just say for a
moment he swung first he did it was
defense I don't care what he says that
he was defense and also yeah when you
attack me I'm gonna kill you look at
where we're at zombies are eating us I
went back and rewatched that that whole
encounter because I was like did you
know who who was attacking first right
they definitely roll up out of nowhere
to come swinging they weren't like hey
you guys want to trade with us they were
like I'm gonna hit this dude in the back
of the head no one's out they're they're
killing asking questions later no one's
asking questions first they just
immediately go into killing people
because he was hungry and he was gonna
eat him either way Joel you know you
know maybe not the best guy but clearly
has we all have a past we all have a
past but if someone swings a baseball
bat at your head and the apocalypse
expect to get choked yeah there was no
friendly confrontation yeah you're
getting choked out I would have just
stomped you in the nuts
now do do we assume they were out there
looking for people to eat like or just
looking for stuff and if they came
across people they gonna eat when they
clearly were going hunting and then they
got they kind of got the deer situation
I wasn't thinking that they were like
looking for yeah but this this group
didn't have guns they had baseball bats
and Hammers and stuff like they're gonna
sneak up on a deer and hit it in the
back of the head you haven't done that
no I am I I think they were looking for
food in general right I think they were
hoping for deer and other things and
food Wings yeah food the most dangerous
game is chasing humans it's the hardest
game as well so why would I go for a
human over a rabbit right I don't know
it seems pretty easy to catch people if
they have a hard time catching gears uh
David confers with James played by Troy
Baker Joy voice Joe in the video games
he's also been the one hosting the last
of us after show the town is running low
on food it has about a week's Supply
maybe two if they can ration or if they
can find someone named Frank uh Joel is
on his last legs and looking rough in
bed uh Ali is running out of food too
she saves the last little bit of jerky
for Joel in case he wakes up while she's
out hunting I I for a second I was
afraid she was a baby bird yeah I knew
we were on the same time I was like I
don't know about this I do like lubing
it right there too with the idea that
like well if he dies I'll come back and
grab this or if he doesn't eat it in a
couple hours I'll take it
upgrades her bow from the games to
Joel's rifle which means the bunny is
able to escape that little Lucky Bastard
uh if you play the game you know the the
bunny's not so lucky I do like that
little twist here she does land a shot
on a stag that manages to run off before
Bleeding Out nearby uh Anna you pointed
this out in your trailer breakdown you
know she's learning the tips she learned
from Joel in episode six before they got
to the college you know breathe uh
squeeze the trigger slowly and it pays
off he's a good teacher he did a great
job you know who's a bad teacher David
Bad Teacher uh and guess who love that
movie I love that movie so the deer gets
away uh but you know who catches up to
that deer oh David and James of course I
thought it was so funny how they were
just like standing
I'm standing there it was kind of funny
well that is weird because you know
someone shot this deer it wasn't another
deer who learned how to use a gun I
guess the first thing I think is like oh
wow that Hunter is really bad because
they shot the deer and now it's all the
way over here and I haven't seen them
yet yeah yeah it did look pretty Frozen
I think it was just kind of covered in
so for a second I was like how long has
that deer been sitting there I think it
got pretty far and she just took her
time to get into it their little moment
of like should we take this deer is it
poisoned is there a bomb inside of this
it was always great and then Ellie
sneaks up behind them and orders them to
drop their weapons and man if she total
John Wick badass in this scene I love it
even like unloading the gut uh with one
hand very smart great very smart David
asked Ellie if she can make uh some kind
of trade and Ellie makes a fatal mistake
blurting out nothing man a bit too fast
to show her desperation David tells
James to run back and get some
penicillin but at this point I don't
trust anything derived from a fungus
which is a yeah yes yes don't don't
trust anything
well clearly it is now but I wouldn't
it's always been good
Bless The Blessed Be the mold that
brought us the farm
we can't go into religious quotes Elian
loads are guns like a [__] badass and
her and David moved to a nearby Shack
David reveals that he only started
worshiping after the world went to [__]
but you gotta think he doesn't actually
believe in this stuff and figured he
could just use it to manipulate people
they say he was a t do you say it was a
math teacher he said he was a oh I don't
know what specific teacher what would
math make a difference I don't know I
never trust a math teacher well I mean
but it does make sense like a teacher
and a kind of a religious leader you're
both you you both contain knowledge that
you are sharing with people who who
either don't understand the knowledge or
don't take the time to understand the
knowledge right that was that's
interesting because I was just taking it
as like oh this creep used his job to be
creepy and then now that we're in a
apocalypse or like this he can now he
probably didn't start being creepy
afterwards no no no no no he was
sleeping before he just could actually
act on them now he did say later when
they're in the cell that he he has lines
about like um you you give the people
what they need to believe and so it
truly is like do you believe this
yourself or are you just kind of using
religion to manipulate hey look here I
had to start a commune somehow he also
mentions that Pittsburgh's qz falling in
2017 likely a nod to the game since they
swapped the Pittsburgh QC for Kansas
City in episode four and five yeah
that's right that's right David
masterfully reveals that he knows
exactly who Ellie is and knows Joe must
be a nearby that was a great sequence I
loved it James appears but High Valley
with a gun to her head but David tells
him to give her the medicine and I don't
know if she was like what the [__] no uh
Ellie leaves they really want to kill
this little girl why they want revenge
Ellie leaves the deer and runs back to
Joe while David and James head back to
Silver Lake Ellie does what any of us
would do while administering penicillin
she just guesses and stabs I do love the
moment of her being like what the [__]
do I do here uh we were all trying to
talk about in the office like uh it from
uh our producer Dazzle did some great
research well apparently you could put
penicillin in the bloodstream or in a
muscle either of those are good directly
the wound I don't know how many days how
much yeah
I have no idea I'm only administered
penicillin to my friend once and I had
to do it in like the role of his stomach
right here but he measured it out but I
think it was like only like five yeah so
in case the world ends uh after you see
this uh aim for the bloodstream aim for
a muscle okay
smart you want to get in there but if
you get in the bloodstream it's probably
going to get to the wounds pretty
quickly can I just drink it uh you could
take it orally sure we're all just sacks
of meat it'll get around somehow we're
all sacks of meat folks delicious sacks
of meat I'm gonna put in my eyebrow like
botox
at the resort the kitchen prepares a
stew for the community oh man in walks a
man with a tub of mystery meaty labels
Venice
I'd be like where'd you guys get
together
I love that reveal because the scene
before that we do see them like they
would get the deer and take it back and
we're like oh yeah that's the deal and
then they walk in with the deer while
everyone's sitting there
mix it with the human meat so it kind of
you know you don't taste how gamey our
meat is right right my wife when we were
watching this episode she she
immediately clocked out like that's not
dear she hadn't played the game before
but she was like something's up here
they're they're focusing too long on the
meat it's like I don't know even when
they start eating the sound of like the
scraping of the forks it's so voracious
you're like this is Sweeney Todd out oh
yeah yeah
physical uh David appears with a deer no
one from town seems excited I clocked
that I was like
me I was like
we start to piece together that maybe
these people didn't elect David as their
leader after all Alex daughter demands
David kill Joel and Ellie and David
backhands her telling her I know you
think
you think and you will show him respect
when he's speaking oh this man this yeah
this was like a great reveal for the
audience like if you think that maybe
this guy is good he is definitely not
good well I don't I'm I'm interested do
do we think he was elected because I
sort of got the vibe that they were more
upset about
um the the choice not to kill Ellie
right away yeah sure I think he's the
opposite of I know I think he's the same
as Kathleen in that regards that he he
was elected he's just kind of now a
Monster yeah now there's no way to undo
it right they've given him the power and
maybe they don't know how to take it
back at this point uh this guy they need
to trust him there's also that idea of
like the sunk cost fallacy of like we've
put all this faith in this person he is
leading us we might as well let him keep
doing what he's doing and he said that
most of these people don't know that
this is yes
if you if you get a good group of not to
no no shade to anything with religion
because my family's really go off uh no
no religion my family is very religious
I will never shade anymore being
religious uh but it's easy to kind of
get people at their weakest moments in a
situation like this and find that like
false faith and they just need someone
to follow so maybe that is what he is
you can look at a lot of instances uh of
you know more dangerous cults throughout
history things like Jonestown where
they're pushed to a point where they're
willing to drink poison uh rather than
succumb to the outside world so it's
dangerous out there folks watch out for
your Math teachers
but ask questions
so everyone says Grace is the community
not creepy at all and they
trepidatiously start eating the mystery
meat which leads us to our gross out
moment of the week brought to you by
quip
[Applause]
that's gross oh you know you know what
else is gross bad breath of tooth decay
thankfully our friends at quip have the
perfect survival kit to keep your oral
gross out moments in check if you need
to get the small fibers of your father's
kidney out of your mouth well quips
water flosser hits all the right spots
gentle or deep clean pressure at the
touch of a button equips electric
toothbrush also has time Sonic
vibrations with 30 second pulses to
guide a dentist recommended two minute
clean the quipocalypse has begun and
quip wants to know whether your favorite
Last of Us character is Joel or Ellie
just go to getquip.com infected and
place your vote by using one of these
promo codes either Joel or Ellie tell us
who your favorite is either code will
automatically get you 20 off in equip
flosser equipped toothbrush or quips gum
starter kit plus if your favorite
character ends up getting the most votes
quick will send you a special power up
to help you fight off those infected
plaque Monsters the contest is almost
over
is
the contest is almost over so be sure to
get your votes in before midnight on
March 8th the winner will be announced
on the final episode breakdown so stay
tuned for that we will also cosplay as
whoever the winner is so be sure to go
to getquip.com infected and use either
promo code Joel or Ellie quit prevents
you from getting blood stains on your
teeth that's right you don't want to
have blood stains on your teeth after
lunch after watching Creed I punch
myself in the face a bunch so I always
have blessings oh my gosh so much okay
moving on back with Joel and Ellie Joel
is looking not so hot oh he's looking
rough the hottest man is looking the
worst today Ellie administers more
medicine and while she's outside taking
in that fresh air she sees some crows
fly off someone nearby very smart and I
always think about that because I'm a
weirdo every time I see a group of birds
fly One Direction I'm like who's over
there I mean you know what a group of
crows is called a murderer you did know
yeah great yeah
sure enough David James and the four
other men are canvassing in the
neighborhood David demands Ellie to be
taken back to Silver Lake because he's a
[__] filthy animal yeah he is uh and
not the good filthy yeah I mean at this
point you might be thinking well maybe
he does no want her to see something in
here that she wants her to survive but
no it's really selfish disgusting reason
as soon as he was like give her the
penicillin I was like red flag right I
was like this guy's gonna do some weird
[__] right right because why would you
give her just kill her okay either I
wouldn't kill Ally I wouldn't kill Ellie
I wouldn't kill Ellie but I understand
their circumstance Ellie Sprints back to
the house and tries to wake Joel up
placing a knife in his hands and
barricading the door he takes off on
Horseback as David's men close in Ellie
distracts them and tries to draw them
off Joel David reiterates he wants Ellie
alive James takes out Ellie's horse and
just as he's ready to pull the trigger
on Ellie herself David stops him
shooting in the air this is a great
little point in your moment too because
of course that's Troy breaker who played
Joe in the game in him holding the gun
to an Ellie is like very interesting I
think that's very interesting we fully
passed that horse death and we don't
know
I mean
I I immediately thought like that's a
that's a ton of meat that's very smart
he said two drag that horse yeah yeah
make sure obviously you don't want that
job dude dragging a horse
I never I thought about that too
immediately and I was like I would have
never been the person fast enough to be
like Oh I'm gonna be on your side like
I'm gonna go look for Joel because I'm
like carrying a horse back to Camp oh
yeah looking for how they would decide
who would stay with who because it was
very like one with me two over there and
the rest over here they just walked in
different directions I was like you
voluntarily went to the horse first yeah
well knowing what happens if you go
after Joe I would take the horse any day
so Ellie left uh Joel with this little
knife and in the cutest little shot of
him like tucked him oh big enough he's
like what do I do
apparently a knife was the only medicine
Joel needed as he you know masterful
moment a man comes down the stairs and
he comes out of their shadows and just
takes them out with one of the most
brutal kills of the season and it's only
about to get more brutal from here on
out he uses Timothy as bait to lure and
one of the other hunters and knocks him
out what follows it was a little
suspension of disbelief that Joel was
able to in the truck he was pushing the
thing able to get up go home remember
when he lost his hearing and he was able
to share but he's had a couple down days
he's been resting he's had a little bit
before he gets up to hide he's just like
oh [__] oh
the jerky that got him back
you know Murder makes the heart grow
fonder I don't know uh so uh what
follows after this death is truly an
unhinged moment from Joel as he
interrogates these two men threatening
to pop off kneecaps and slice throats I
mean woof I grabbed my leg and sting
instinctually but the idea of him
popping out the kneecap just great just
great and it really showed this is the
most vicious and ruthless we've seen
Joel in the show and it shows this is
what he's willing to do for Ellie if he
thinks Ellie's in danger he'll reach
that point and we haven't seen that so
far right uh Joel gets the answers he's
looking for and kills the two uh members
of what I'm calling the Silver Lake
All-Stars
oh yeah oh well no you don't want to be
on that one
I do love the idea of like he told you
what you wanted to know I was like yeah
too bad
back in Silver Lake Ellie wakes up to
David watching her creep while David
Goes to get her food Ellie spots the ear
left over from last night's Feast can
someone box that up for me please clean
up your your workstations folks you
can't leave ears on the ground yeah this
girl's gonna figure out very quickly
that you eat humans real quick you I
think you're all pieced together like
she sees something that Clues her in on
their eating people right what did you
think she was gonna see I thought finger
I thought finger was what she was gonna
see I found a whole limb yeah I thought
it was going to be a full
legal like he was like intentionally he
wanted her to see the like legs or that
like he threw her in there and was like
oh I forgot the legs and it was almost
like when you did see that you're like
oh it's not that bad
what's gonna indicate that it's a human
right it's protein well I was like that
indicates that they don't eat the ear
when I'm a horrible person I watch a lot
of horror movies and when I saw the dead
bodies later on I was like oh yeah you
go for the stomach first get rid of the
head well and I think in a world where
you're risking getting your kneecaps
popped off by a knife you got to eat as
much cartilage as you can the ears
cartilage you want that in your body no
you don't want that crunchiness because
they're gonna taste all that and be like
this is not going to know you're eating
people if you're in on it I'll leave the
ears you want me to chew on the goddamn
me if I'm David I'm eating the ear
that's all I'm saying that's all I'm
saying you could you know they make like
the the rinds out of pig's ears that's
right
uh for dogs dogs lay pigs ears pork rind
is usually fried pig skin uh quite
delicious you can get chicharrones which
usually involves more of the intestine
if you're into that because if you're
out there somewhere
I think you'd want to sous-vide it you
know what I mean you want to keep it
nice and tender David invites Ellie to
join him to be as equal in this
community
to be his his wife his child wife Ellie
learns from the mistakes she made in the
earlier episode and expertly turns the
table on David I can tell the others to
stop looking for him
they'll spare him
really
just let him go
they follow me
follow us luring David in closer so she
can steal the key off of his hip very
smart I would never have done this
because I'm an idiot Ellie breaks
David's fingers but can't get to his
keys in time and David tells her she's
getting chopped up into tiny little
pieces I mean realistically though if
she did get the keys and they're
standing outside
right here
there we go we're gonna just eat your
stomach quicker now we're gonna catch
you open we're gonna cut you open uh
David returns with James and a butcher
knife and Ali tells them she's infected
in a very smart move and now David is
too quick thinking Ellie this was so
smart I was like oh great great idea uh
and just a [__] masterful move that
made me leap out of my chair right when
I was I screamed I scared my neighbors
Ellie Cleaves James yep in a brutal
fashion him just sitting there like oh
whoopsie I
David what are we gonna do about this
I guess I'm dinner now she makes her
Escape into the restaurant's dining room
setting it on fire sort of accidentally
while hiding from David David tells
Ellie that he's going to keep her and
Ellie Casper said because Casper was
enough freaking monster yeah at the end
he says can I keep you
he says that the cat Okay Christine
Christina Ritchie that that is true uh
be wary of global preachers and ghosts
folks uh Ellie makes her move with a
kitchen knife getting a nice little uh
stab uh into David in the abdomen Ellie
makes a move for the butcher knife but
David is able to research her on the
ground and threatens to assault her
Ellie gets a hold of the butcher knife
and gives David exactly what he deserves
and even when we want her to stop she
does is she keeps going I love how the
camera gets covered it gets like who who
wants her to stop well no you know I
mean the deed's done but let her chop
this man into a million pieces I mean
want her to stop in order to get out of
the room that's currently on Fiverr fire
I love the like kind of this place has
become the hell that it always was right
like we are now in the fire and
brimstone and this man is just chopped
to death visceral chunks getting on the
camera lens I loved it this is this
scene has been used so many times in uh
every movie every TV show and I love it
so much every everyone does someone like
Overkill it's like
ready or not at the very end she's just
mutilating these bodies because they
were hunting her the entire movie it's
just like being hunted being prey the
entire time you just are fed up at the
end and you just go crazy you let
yourself go crazy and I love that
execution that they did in this I think
the cinematographer did a great job so
the director beautiful stuff outside
Joel finds Ellie who she fears is
another one of David's men and the two
are finally safe they continue on foot
right into the lake and the show's over
forever because they freeze to death the
end no they're heading to Salt Lake City
as we saw on that map uh back at episode
six where they believe the fireflies to
be now they saw all those Trails going
to Salt Lake City and we're out we're
out by Silver Lake
we hate you I love that the every place
they go they leave like a little piece
of themselves behind in it like it's
this place is going to be set on fire
and it's like this is what they did when
they left Joel or when I left uh Tommy
it's like yeah here's a little piece of
us also still back here with the blood
and all this [__] that we left I was
kind of surprised not to see more of the
Silver Lake All-Stars come running out
be like hey why is our Steakhouse is
dinner ready I think all the bad ones
they're all bad I guess both of them
didn't know I don't think a lot of like
the women and the younger people knew
but uh all like his troop were all the
ones that got murdered because I kept
paying attention to even the first time
I watched that I kept paying attention
to the women in the audience and I was
like I think he is abusing most if not
all of these women yeah there's a lot of
uh kind of tense fear and just they're
like too afraid to actually because no
when he smacks that little girl right no
one jumps up and I was like David what
the heck that one woman does for a
minute and then she sits back down and
that's where I was like oh okay these
people are too too afraid to interfere
with anything yeah so I don't think like
a lot of people knew that these hunting
parties that were going out were
bringing back people clearly you know
they didn't not everyone was in on the
people eating uh yeah real quick before
we get into some of the other questions
when Joel finds those bodies hanging in
next to the horse again ton of meat on
the horse do you think those were people
who died in the community and they were
chopping them a medium or do you think
those are other people they may have
found along their way you know because
uh he has the line about not burying the
girl's father until the spring right I
think it's probably community members I
don't know if they've killed but that
have died but regardless or or
but I do think the line about not
bearing the father till spring is an
insinuation that he might be hanging up
there right they definitely can't eat
the ones that got infected yeah they
couldn't eat anyone well I don't know
well let's my big question coming out of
this episode that I want to ask the both
of you is do you think Ellie could have
actually infected David is that possible
because we do have some precedent for
people carrying for example kova 19 that
are asymptomatic and never never come
down with the illness but they do pass
it on to other people so my question is
do you think in this show in this world
that cordyceps uh if Ellie doesn't
change she never becomes effective with
it but is it still alive with inside of
her if David had lived on Beyond this
moment could he have uh turned it's
what's interesting is that she she reads
is infected to those Federal scanners
right something's so active in there
that's a good point but I I but the dog
didn't smell it I feel like from game
knowledge and I'm not gonna say what
that is at all I feel like maybe we can
talk about that in the spoiler corner
but
um I feel like no it doesn't have to do
with her bodily fluids I feel like the
fungus has to be active in some way in
the body maybe for it to spread via
white or saliva because we don't know
what those Federal scanners are scanning
true is it like the leftover remnants of
of of the cordyceps uh or is it like an
active living version of the uh uh of
the fungus because our wound never heals
but it's a scar at this point it's on an
open festering wind it did look it
almost looked a little bit worse this
episode like when she rolled it up I was
like oh girl maybe she was flexing to
make it really stand down she should
have smeared a little blood on it you
know what I mean to make it look look
pretty fresh uh but I did love that
moment of paranoia immediately from
James where he's like what what you have
it now I gotta kill you what's going on
and you know David very quickly being
like know we've seen her for hours and
hours now she would have she would have
changed by now do you think she could
still Sprint it Jessica I don't think so
but I like your argument with covid-19
because it is Airborne but like a
horrible example HIV is not that has to
be through bodily fluid it has to be
blood to blood or it has to get absorbed
into your mouth is on hint of oxygen it
usually dies yeah more than often like
97 but so it's like it like into
someone's eyes would that work or just
you have to get it I think it has she
has to get that injection right put that
blood into someone else to give it to
them but her situation where she's
immune could be the reason why her blood
wouldn't cause someone to turn right
because she's like immune to it so
that's why I'm like if someone had I
hate that I only know so much about HIV
and AIDS because I taught sex ed when I
was younger
um that it's like there are people that
have the immunity to the HIV to the to
AIDS but they can get HIV but they
naturally have the immunity to AIDS so
those people they test their blood and
they're trying to test it with other
people to see if they can get rid of
that situation where it gets to AIDS so
I'm like is that the kind of situation
we're getting with Ellie more than it is
covid-19 uh well you can still carry it
but she'll never never turn yeah she'll
never turn she's carrying the the
cordyceps whatever so that's why I was
like blanking here looking in the camera
for a long time while they were talking
you were trying to do all your
institutional knowledge yeah I was like
well this is what happens yeah and I
know it's like we see her try the blood
swap thing on Sam but he was already
gonna turn yeah yeah it's not a definite
answer
I don't think she can pass it on but it
is very interesting that she still scans
as positive yeah that is a good point
but yeah the dog doesn't smell it so
what we don't know exactly what they're
scanning what the dog is smelling that's
why I'm saying is like I think it's her
specific blood yeah like if you did it
to another infected person took their
blood out with the syringe and put in
someone else they get it but with Ellie
because she's immune it's the thing
that's in her blood right that makes it
so it's like yeah it shows up on all
these scanners that you have it but once
you give it to someone else it just
doesn't work because it cancels out
people are around infected like either
captured infected or like you know uh
recently deceased infected they walk
around where we can see the fungus on
the ground and stuff this show is kind
of said that the spores as far as we
know are not going to happen something
in the game where there are spores that
you can inhale and become infected in
closed spaces the the Craig Mason and
Neil druckman have said on the the after
Show podcast they're like ah the spores
don't really work in this world that was
kind of a game device that we needed
they've kind of insinuated they're not
going to to do that you can inhale the
cordyceps and become infected that way
this season at least and this season at
least we'll see we'll see what happens
uh but we all know the show's over
because Joel and Ellie walks into the
lake and that's the end it doesn't
really matter it doesn't really matter
anymore uh but it would be interesting
if if it turns out that Ellie could give
it to people I mean what a superpower to
be like I can give it to you but I will
never turn look here [__] look here
I'll bite you I'll bite you yeah because
again it's we don't see the the infected
need to bite someone as far as we know
if an infected quartus have walked up to
you it's like ah you know that might not
turn you right oh God I'm sorry I hope
that doesn't turn you I hope that
doesn't turn you I'm safe I'm safe uh
but what a superpower
a superpower I also I did appreciate how
David knew about corniceps he was wise
to it it's interesting how much of the
information of this has kind of spread
throughout the world uh that they know
everyone even Joel knew that like this
is all cordyceps like they figured it
all out I find that fascinating I don't
know they hadn't they were they had had
to travel there from sure they've gone
across across the country Middle East
through the place
uh well if you recently recovered from a
nearly fatal stab wound on a mattress
and bled all over it maybe it's time to
get a new mattress thankfully our
friends at Helix can help you do just
that Helix makes premium mattresses and
bedding that are customized to fit your
needs and conveniently shipped right to
your door Helix made a sleep quiz that
matches your unique body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you so you don't have to worry about
which one to get based on your different
sleep positions and firmness preferences
they have something for everyone's
unique taste and if you sleep with a
partner lucky you you can take the Sleep
quiz together and find something that's
the perfect compromise for you both
Jessica you have a helix mattress right
you're a lucky duck you love it it's
extra soft and I got the one that makes
you cold because I run hot it makes you
cold yeah the bed's naturally cold oh
okay I just thought it said mean things
to you to make you feel bad on the
inside yeah it made me icy so I run
pretty high my wife steals all my heat
at night I need a mattress that puts a
wall up between us yeah mattress for two
people too yeah you have a partner right
you're not sleeping alone all by
yourself crying yourself alone actually
I have a cat oh okay I have a body
pillow
combo brag
well whatever mattress you prefer Helix
will deliver it right to your door with
free shipping in the US plus Helix has a
100 night sleep trial so you get more
than three months to make sure that you
love it or you get a full refund Helix
mattresses have a 10 year warranty they
even offer financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away if
you're looking for a new bed check out
Helix you can click the link below or go
to helixsleep.com break room to get 20
off your Helix mattress plus two free
pillows that's helixsleep.com break room
we also want to thank factor for
sponsoring us today power up for
Springtime with Factor America's number
one ready to eat meal kit get nutritious
Chef prepared meals delivered straight
to your door leaving you time and energy
to tackle everything on your to-do list
no need to go out looking for rabbits
and deer Factor will deliver food that
is not humans straight to your door
yeah yeah I don't know uh uh even if
you're too busy to cook Factor will help
you skip the trip to the grocery store
and Skip The Chopping prepping and
cleaning up too factors fresh never
frozen meals are ready in just two
minutes so all you have to do is heat
and enjoy they have delicious
flavor-packed meals to help you live to
the fullest choose from keto vegan and
veggie calorie smart and Protein Plus
options on the menu each week prepared
by chefs and approved by dietitians each
meal has all the ingredients you need to
feel satisfied all day long yes yes a
lot of us here at gift Factory it's
really great we're busy people you know
one and the keto one's amazing though
the keto one's phenomenal how many like
weekly options are there though it's a
ton that's a great question I wish I had
an answer for you oh wait I do they have
over 34 Chef prepared dietitian approved
weekly options there's always something
new to try on the site enjoy meals for
any time of day with breakfast options
like egg bites smoothies and more or you
can eat dinner for breakfast who cares
it's your life don't let Society tell
you what you can eat for breakfast
plus you can replace your snack Supply
with an assortment of over 45 add-ons
get factor and enjoy clean eating
without the hassle simply choose your
meals and enjoy fresh flavor-packed
meals delivered to your door ready in
just two minutes no prep No Mess head to
factormeals.com break room 50 and use
code break room 50 to get what 50 off
your first box that's called break room
50 at Factor meals.com break room 50 to
get 50 off your first box okay Anna why
don't you tell us about some of the
differences uh from the game to the show
will I always just have to have a little
stretch to get ready there's so many
changes uh Hey folks this is where we're
going to be talking about the game if
you want to go in blind to the game and
you don't want to know anything about
the differences this is your time to
click off uh coming from your friendly
neighborhood Anna who doesn't want to
spoil anything for you so we're jumping
into it for
as we said the bunnies the bunny escapes
escapes this chapter in the game has a
cold open with a cute little winter
bunny hopping out before it's close up
just shot in the head with an arrow and
falls over it there's a there's a great
meme out there you can check out of a
streamer playing the game for the first
time I believe and coming to the bunny
scene and finding it very cute and then
being utterly devastating when it gets
shot through the head with an error also
how close was she gonna be this rabbit
with the rifle as she walked up to him
little fur cloud
also a lot of the a lot of the aspects
of David and the villagers is new
um him being they focus a lot more on
religion with like him being a preacher
the whole town being very religious
there is some of us in the game I talked
about a bit in my trailer breakdown for
the episode
um they do have like the banner and he
has a few quotes he says religious
quotes he says while he well in combat
but they really put a lot more of an
emphasis on this also him like having
the past as the teacher you know things
like that the the young girl who he
slaps that's all new
um so a lot of like Community Building
Davis character building sort of things
like that we're new
um also as we mentioned before she uses
a bow instead of the rifle at first to
do her hunting uh and then eventually
trades it for David's rifle and what I
loved you talked about like uh taking
out the bullets and in in a lot of times
when games are just like oh I'll pick up
more shotguns but in real life you can't
have a shot you can't pick up more
shotgun in the game you're carrying a
water a lot of weapons point in the game
a lot of explosives very dangerous
really impressive rifle hands three
handguns it's very cool
um also David is hiding a handgun that
Ellie doesn't know about when they're
sitting around the fire a horde of
infected started to come and so they
have to work together Friday off he
pulls out a handgun she's like you had a
gun the whole time he's like sorry sorry
I'm a liar builds her trust in him
because he didn't pull the gun on her
when he had it the whole time it's all
part of the grand scheme of things uh
there's also that side mission of having
to take out all of the infected that are
swarming around and Escape them which
they left out which I thought they'd
probably leave out yeah lots of that
like we gotta make this is a show not a
game right game not a show there's also
there's a bloated
which also got emitted so there you go
sorry sorry bloater extra you got cut
you got cut you got got uh they cut a
few gameplay bits with Ellie trying to
escape David's men and like getting into
the lodge or getting grabbed there's
also like a bunch of gameplay where
they're both running through the storm
we got a taste of it with Joel running
through the storm and all the winds yeah
and stuff like that but Ellie also has a
section like that the Joel kneecap
torture stuff is absolutely in the game
though and I I could have sworn they
were gonna lighten it up I did not
lighten that up it was brutal man they
leaned in hard uh in the show Ellie
actually eats the food that David gives
her which is a little sauce in the game
she's like uh he's like she said what is
it and he's like venison he's like oh
the side of human a really cool one guy
one line kind of right right I love how
she immediately kicked it away and was
like I'm not eating that he's like for
what it's worth it is deer yeah well in
the show she did
show they really leaned in with uh his
sort of sadism and affection for Ellie
yeah and his um his uh
oh his intentions with her uh in the
game it's
I I personally believe that they did
have that that was in the game that
there were more uh sexually nefarious
intentions but it is uh some people
didn't get that from the game
um but it's definitely if it was meant
it's a much more clear Chapman went oh
no let's make this clear yeah he is
definitely a very bad person with very
bad intentions
um so that whole speech about his
intentions when she's in the cage and
when uh in the burning building that
speech is a lot longer and more uh
defined I guess sure sure and much more
creepy
great so there's also there's one more
change or one more big change that's
different from the show in the game that
I want to get y'all's opinion on uh in
the game she continues hacking away at
his face it's very clear it's his face
in the game too I feel like uh until
Joel actually finds her and has to like
hold her wrist and stop her and that's
when they have that moment of her like
being in shock and things like that uh
in this in the show it happens outside
after she already leaves the building
how do we what do we even think about
this change I I like giving her the
agency of being like you can you can
shop up this man for as long as you like
and Joel's not there to stop it's up to
you like let her go how long you want to
stop how long you want to chop that's up
to you girl yeah you do your thing part
of me thinks it was a practical choice
because he has the line about all the
doors are locked and I have the keys
David says that and so it is kind of
like how would you all get in there but
if something's burning that's a great
point and it is also it shows that like
it's up to at least if you want to die
here chopping this man up you that's
your choice too because in her mind I do
love they never pulled like a Joel's
dead we gotta move to to mess with her
but in her mind she could be very
worried that Joel is dead and she's on
her own now and this is she she could be
willing to die here killing this man but
that's up to her but she doesn't she she
chooses When to Walk Away there is very
much a moment of her almost feeling like
she's seeing a ghost like not being able
to believe that it's actually Joel there
yeah um because uh last she left him he
was a cute little boy in the bed with a
little burrito burrito with a knife
sick uh real quick let's hit our kill
counts for the episode Ellie coming in
with two beautiful kills Joe got three
gruesome kills and the Silver Lake
All-Stars they took down one horse
R.I.P to nameless horse we never got the
horse's name let's call him Denver wow
we miss you Denver
uh some quick spoiler talk
um this is the spoilers to spoiler
things off we could talk about the next
uh game too we can talk about whatever
we want so the finale you've been warned
the finale episode is next week folks we
know the creators have told us to expect
the unexpected even for people who've
played the game so we're going to take a
stab at some predictions for things that
didn't happen in the game but could
happen in the show I this is one I think
we might see uh the death of Riley Riley
actually dying at the hands of Valley
Ali happened to kill Riley I think would
be heavy and I think it could be an
intense flashback for her knowing what's
coming up are you voting yes I'm voting
we will see Ali kill Riley and it's
gonna be heavy heavy I vote no no I
think they're done I think they're gonna
leave it no more Riley no we never said
O'Reilly what about you uh what about
you no but I think it's because I agree
with the third one oh okay
uh do we think we'll see anything
related to Abby to set up season two
um we know Abby plays a big part in in
game part two we know that a a doctor
who we're going to see in the next
episode who has a heavy fate uh is the
father of Abby do you think they will
plant any seeds with Abby uh in this
season knowing that they they know
they're getting season two it's been a
confirmed I think Abby will start the
second season okay if we get a little
bit we start with Abby yeah or I mean we
start with Ellie I mean I think it would
be powerful knowing what's about to
happen to start with yeah
because I feel like this last episode
will just wrap it up right like it'll be
like even if it isn't like the game
right it's still going to end with like
them walking away because they they did
they did set up Dina maybe they were
very yeah Craig Mason was very quiet
about was that Dina but it was like it's
dinner we don't know if it'll be the
same actress coming back to play that
role but what do you think and you think
we'll see anything with Abby before this
this this season comes to an end
I think that
if they do it'll be set up in the same
way like that Marlene's brother was
it'll be like an offhanded comment about
a daughter like him being like yeah my
daughter watches that show and like
that's it only some very small well here
they do it we'll hear the doctor talk
mention his daughter yeah but I mean
they've in the past episodes and like
this last one they set up the girl's
father died at the beginning of the
episode and that type in they have been
setting little breadcrumbs throughout
the season so that might be a change in
the game they don't he never says
anything about a daughter you find that
out in game two but since they already
know what happens in game two yeah they
might leave a little breadcrumbs I think
the doctor kiss a little girl on the
head and be like Daddy will be back
after surgery
after a success that's a promise hey and
if I lie to you you kill whoever who
killed you make that promise to me
yeah yeah what about some uh some
history between Marlene and Ellie's
parents Marlene's made it very clear
that she was good friends with Ellie's
mom Ellie doesn't know who her mom is
she remember she asked Marlene are you
my mommy and Marlene was like the [__]
you talking about uh bulldozer do you
think we'll get any sort of like
flashback or Marlene talking about her
parents or anything like that yeah
yes I mean we'll see at this point we'll
have the episode trailer which the the
season trailer featured uh uh Ellie's
mom and her as a baby so it's got to be
in the last one okay good good call I
agree you agree you agree all right okay
uh I think so that makes the most sense
yeah yeah of course that is it for this
episode of the break room we'll be back
next week to discuss the season finale
but we also do the show every day live
at 3 P.M talking about all the nerdy
news that you guys love and need to know
about follow me at Lulu underscore
Clemens follow Brandon at grin and
Barrick follow Anna it's Anna vanston
subscribe to the break room wherever you
get your podcast and we'll see you guys
on Tuesday thanks for watching see you
at dinner yum yum yum yum yum
foreign
[Music]